très notre invité politique ce matin
c'est Hervé Marseille bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
sénateurs des Hauts de scène président
du groupe Union centriste au Sénat et
président de l'UDI vous êtes avec nous
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Julien Lecuyer de la
Voix du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour
monsieur
le
coran livre un nouveau rapport sur
l'équilibre financier du système et il
dit que contrairement à ce qui a été
premier par le gouvernement la réforme
des retraites ne ramènera pas
l'équilibre financier du système en 2030
le système sera à nouveau en déficit
tout ça pour ça cette réforme elle a
servi à pas grand chose
ça aurait pu être pire si on n'avez pas
fait la réforme donc à l'évidence il est
clair qu'il y avait besoin d'une réforme
je veux dire c'est la justification et
quand
les parties et de gauche et les
syndicats dénoncés
l'idée même de réformes on voit bien
qu'il y avait besoin d'une réforme donc
déjà avec les effets de la réforme on
n'atteint pas l'objectif donc ça veut
dire est-ce que ce que ce rapport dit
finalement c'est que on en a pas fini
avec la réforme des retraites et qu'il
faut s'attendre à une nouvelle réforme
dans quelque chose bien sûr dans le
texte qui a été voté on nous avons prévu
ce qu'on a appelé une clause de revoyure
de façon à évaluer la situation
[Musique]
du quinquennat effectivement ça va
vouloir dire nouvelle réforme avec
nouveau report de l'âge légal de départ
si vous voyez la clause de revoyeur
c'est intervient en 2027 étonnamment il
se passe quelque chose en 2027 donc à
l'évidence tous les candidats aux
élections présidentielles devront dire
ce qu'ils pensent de ce dossier et
qu'est-ce qu'il propose pour apporter
une réponse et je pense que
on échappera pas une nouvelle réforme
avec un report de l'âge encore décalé si
on en croit le corps enfin on commence à
s'endormir
il faut il faut regarder de près quand
même ce qui raconte ces gens-là on a
l'impression qu'ils disent un peu dans
le marc de café donc il y a encore
beaucoup d'incertitudes et de paramètres
qui échappent mais on voit bien que les
les effets de la réforme
n'importe quelque chose heureusement
mais qu'il faut aller encore plus loin
il faut aller encore plus loin et
reporter encore là au-delà de 64 ans je
pense qu'il faudra revenir certainement
à des fondamentaux pour ce qui nous
concerne nous avons toujours été
favorable à une réforme avec une
retraite à points comme celle qui avait
été prévue à l'époque d'Édouard Philippe
qui était assez
consensuel on s'en souvient à l'époque
ce qui a mis
les difficultés c'est je crée pivot mais
sinon sur le principe même de la
retraite à points c'était quelque chose
qui était porté d'ailleurs par la CFD et
qui était assez consensuel faudra
peut-être réfléchir à revenir à des
choses beaucoup plus structurelles on
parle des soulèvements de la terre
Julien oui puisqu'il y a le gouvernement
a annoncé la dissolution par décret du
collectif écologiste les soulèvements de
la Terre vous supportez le gouvernement
sur cette décision bien sûr on peut pas
accepter les violences
de quelques pas que ce soit je veux dire
dans le débat public il y a beaucoup
trop de violence il y a beaucoup trop de
de gens qui qui s'attaquent au bien et
aux personnes on peut plus avoir une
manifestation sans qu'il y ait des Black
Blocs sans qu'on casse sans qu'on blesse
quelquefois qu'on cherche à tuer même
quand on voit les armes qui sont trouvés
sur les personnes donc je crois que on
attend de l'État qu'il fasse preuve de
fermeté et je crois que cette réponse
est une est une réponse à la violence
qui existe et je regrette que des forces
politiques notamment les Verts
alors justement les vers Marine
Tondelier a réagi hier la patronne des
Verts en jugeant qu'on voulait assimiler
l'écologie à la à la violence pour
occulter le fond des problèmes mais dit
les sous les noms de la terre devient le
bouc émissaire de l'inaction climatique
du gouvernement
enfin je veux dire à Sainte Soline c'est
tout sauf de l'écologie
souvenez-vous de Notre Dame des Landes
il comme ça des rassemblements qui sous
couverts j'allais dire d'écologie ou
d'environnement
finalement aboutissent à des situations
violentes le maire de Toulouse hier soir
a été prise à partie violemment dans sa
vie par des gens qui se réclamaient des
croyez que la dissolution va réellement
régler le problème de cette violence
dans le débat non mais c'est un élément
déjà de fermeté si on laisse faire ça va
pas cristalliser encore plus je crois
qu'il y a la réponse déjà à la violence
c'est la fermeté de la part de l'état de
la justice et de tous ceux qui doivent
assurer l'ordre public qu'on proteste
qu'on manifeste des opinions c'est un
droit constitutionnel et c'est
totalement légitime et il faut le
défendre mais qu'on le fasse en voulant
imposer les idées par la violence c'est
un sujet c'est pas une criminalisation
de l'écologie comme le disent les
écologistes c'est pas le problème de
l'écologie ça serait la défense des
animaux ce serait la défense de je ne
sais quelle opinion ça serait pareil on
peut pas laisser s'installer dans le
débat public
des gens qui veulent imposer des idées
par la violence dernière petite question
sur ce sur ce sujet là dans la majorité
se pose la question de sanctionner les
élus qui participent à des
manifestations illégales avec leur
écharpe tricolore qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
c'est la justice d'apprécier et il faut
peut-être voir les textes mais c'est
vrai que c'est insupportable quand vous
avez des manifestations qui sont
interdites bon et vous êtes élu vous
êtes président de groupe est-ce que vous
cautionnez que des élus des
parlementaires se rendent dans des
manifestations interdites évidemment que
non je veux dire le propre des élus
c'est déjà de respecter la loi et les
règlements qui se manifestent par des
écrits qui se manifestent en venant
devant votre micro expliquer leur
opinion oui ça c'est leur devoirs mais
s'associer sur le terrain à des
violences ça c'est pas supportable on va
parler de la question de la dépense
publique qui inquiète les sénateurs il y
a eu quatre questions d'actualité hier
au Sénat au gouvernement là-dessus le
gouvernement qui a annoncé en début de
semaine 10 milliards d'économies pour
réduire la dépense publique au minimum
puisqu'on parle de 12 milliards pour le
budget 2024 des réductions dans le
domaine de la santé du logement des
aides au carburant vous soutenez cette
politique du gouvernement
évidemment que ça je veux dire enfin
c'était une politique continue depuis
des années
qui va à l'encontre de l'autonomie des
collectivités on peut pas dire bah c'est
à vous de vous gérez vous êtes obligé
d'avoir des budgets d'ailleurs qui soit
en équilibre et puis en même temps année
après année retirer des subventions
retirer des tags etc
35 milliards d'impôts qui ont été
retirés entre la taxe d'habitation la
CVAE était à chaque fois on dit on va
compenser c'est une blague c'est
compenser à peu près la première année
puis après c'est moins 10% chaque année
on voit bien ce qu'il en est et c'est
l'État qui paye c'est à dire qu'il
suffit qu'après il tourne les robinets
c'est ce qui est en train de se faire
alors on fait un peu de cinéma on vous
invite à Bercy on vous sert un verre de
banga puis on vous dit ah ben on va
faire les un conseil des finances enfin
tout ça pour pourquoi pour prendre aux
collectivités chaque année un peu plus
donc vous travaillerez pas avec Gabriel
Attal sur l'élaboration du budget 2024
parce que lui il veut travailler avec
les parlementaires
déjà ils ont augmenté les fonctionnaires
territoriaux pourquoi pas
récemment un détail ils ont oublié d'en
parler à leurs employeurs c'est à dire
aux collectivités si vous apprenez du
jour au lendemain que vous allez devoir
augmenter vos personnels ça peut se
discuter quand même donc ça commence mal
donc ils ont eu raison de boycotter la
réunion de Bercy il faut repartir sur
sur d'autres bases c'est pas on
inventant des machins supplémentaires il
y en a déjà 40 le Conseil l'Observatoire
etc est-ce que les collectivités n'ont
pas quand même aussi le devoir dans un
contexte général d'économie à s'atteler
aussi à la tâche oui mais les
collectivités petit ou grandes elles ont
elles sont le dernier maillon face à la
population
une commune
ces derniers espoirs pour ceux qui ne
vont pas bien parce que il y a des
politiques des lois
qui sont générales et le maire et les
élus locaux eux ils appliquent ça
finement ils savent dans la commune qui
va pas bien qui est en difficulté les
enfants qu'il faut surveiller à qui il
faut donner à manger dans les cantines
etc etc c'est le dernier rempart social
donc si vous retirez de l'argent aux
collectivités c'est encore un maillon
social que vous dégradez
en période de sénatoriale c'est sûr
qu'on va peut-être pas se risquer à se
fâcher avec les collectivités
[Musique]
pas très consensuel en ce moment malgré
tout est-ce que vous pensez qu'avec des
avancées du gouvernement et puissent y
avoir un consensus avec les centristes
je pense qu'il faut un texte sur
l'immigration
nous avons travaillé sur les retraites
on peut pas dire que c'était très
populaire
mais on l'a voté parce que on pensait
qu'il fallait le faire c'était
nécessaire on l'a dit tout à l'heure et
au combien l'immigration je pense que
c'est un sujet que les Français
attendent et pas seulement on voit en
Europe les ravages
et le sujet il est avant tout européen
regardez ce qui s'est passé Annecy
l'auteur
de l'attentat à Annecy il venait de
Suède bon moi j'étais j'ai posé une
question hier sur le Maroc bon j'étais
au Maroc avec le groupe d'amitié
Christian Cambon
récemment les Marocains ils vous disent
les problèmes des visas c'est humiliant
sont pas contents mais s'ils veulent
venir en France il passe par l'Espagne
tous les pays en disant ils vont déposer
27 demandes on a la question européenne
je l'entends bien sûr pour pour ce qui
concerne le projet de loi immigration là
à l'heure actuelle Gérald Darmanin
semble faire de une priorité de
reprendre le texte qui a été déjà passé
en commission sénatoriale en mars est-ce
que pour vous il faut remettre à plat
tout ça partir de du texte que que vous
comptez déposer comment comment on
avance je pense qu'il y a un texte
gouvernement fera ce qu'il veut par
définition mais je pense qu'il y a un
texte qui a été voté par la commission
des lois au Sénat et pas parfait et sur
mon perfectible il y a encore beaucoup
de choses à discuter mais je pense que
ça peut être une bonne base de départ
après il y a ce qu'on peut
dans dans l'idéal
espérer notamment concernant certains
sujets constitutionnels
nous nous proposons mais on n'est pas
les seuls que effectivement les visas et
les autorisations puissent être faites à
l'extérieur du territoire national c'est
dans les ambassades et consulat ça évite
que les gens viennent et demandent des
papiers une fois qu'ils sont arrivés sur
le territoire donc ça ça suppose
à la constitution les trois cinquièmes
du Parlement
on n'est pas mais enfin ça c'est dans
l'idéal après sur le reste il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont partagées
parce que c'est des améliorations sur
administratif sur toutes sortes de
procédures
le point d'accroche c'est la
régularisation
nos amis républicains eux sont hostiles
à l'idée de régulariser et nous nous
pensons
un métier en tension bien sûr pensons
que
des gens qui travaillent depuis au moins
cinq ou sept ans dans des restaurants
sur des chantiers ce qui conclus une
réalité économique qui mettrait en
difficulté notre propre économie
ça demande a été examinée d'abord c'est
pas énormément de gens sont des gens qui
travaillent déjà on regularis amène des
taxes il paye des impôts et puis on peut
travailler à la remise en état de ses
conventions collectives qu'on n'a pas
touché depuis des années afin d'essayer
avec la formation d'amener d'autres gens
des Français d'origine qui puissent
travailler dans ces métiers là sinon ça
restera définitivement des trappes à bas
salaire et des métiers en tension et
donc vous êtes prêt à voter le texte de
Gérald Darmanin pour vous il y a pas de
ligne rouge
toute façon par définition il y a pas de
ligne rouge on discute dialogue on
essaie de faire avancer le texte
je veux dire j'ai pas à me substituer à
eux dans vos propositions là
je suis pas rentré dans le détail
technique il y a toute une litanie de
choses mais le point principal c'est sur
c'est sur la régularisation après nous
nous souhaitons pas porter atteinte aux
règles européennes en revanche on peut
discuter
comme la proposer et Édouard Philippe de
l'accord franco-algérien et donc nous
nous souhaitons d'ailleurs oui il faut
remettre à plat et nous ferons une
proposition qui consiste à évaluer
l'ensemble par un groupe de travail ou
une commission des
accords bilatéraux parce qu'on parle de
l'accord avec l'Algérie mais il y en a
tout un tas d'autres il y en a tout un
tas d'autres avec des pays africains ou
avec
un groupe d'études une commission
spéciale chargée de ça pour faire le
bilan
de tous ces accords bilatéraux pour les
évaluer et savoir parce qu'il y a pas
qu'avec l'Algérie où il faut remettre à
plat les accords on a signé depuis
plusieurs décennies tout un tas
d’accords avec des pays notamment
africains et donc il faut regarder où on
en est et pourquoi on maintient ces
accords monsieur Marseille c'est cette
question mais émigratoires je sens
qu'elle provoque une certaine une
certaine fracture avec les lèvres qui se
crisaient qui se cristallise
on sent qu'il y a des divergences de
plus en plus grandes par rapport aussi à
l'axe de vers lequel les républicains
vont à travers des États généraux et ce
qui a pas un moment donné où vous dites
finalement est-ce que notre chemin
idéologique il n'a pas se séparer à un
moment donné des républicains
écoutez
les républicains ont lancé les états
généraux de la droite bon
il y a pas de problème c'est c'est un
choix qui le font
est-ce que vous aussi vous dites
avec eux
est-ce que vous
à l'orientation que prennent que
prennent les les républicains certains
signaux de certains membres d'entre eux
est-ce qu'à un moment donné vous dites
est-ce que j'ai encore à travailler avec
ces gens-là au sein de du Palais du
Luxembourg
la question de se pose pas on verra à
l'issue des travaux des républicains
quel est leur choix parce que ils ont
choisi de faire ces états généraux j'ai
dit c'est étagère de la droite pourquoi
faire et avec qui
pourquoi faire et avec qui
quelles alliances qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent faire qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
faire et avec qui
veulent rester indépendant oui d'accord
avec le gouvernement est-ce que c'est
une ligne que vous partagez est-ce que
pour vous l'avenir de la droite et du
centre c'est un alliance avec le
gouvernement le problème c'est pas un
problème d'alliance c'est aujourd'hui on
va des textes vote des textes c'est pas
parce qu'il y a une alliance c'est
simplement savoir quel procédure on mène
pour voter ses textes est-ce qu'on le
fait cas par cas
en sachant pas très bien ce qui va se
passer ou est-ce que on discute pour
savoir un petit peu quel est le l'ordre
du jour et les conditions dans
lesquelles on discute puisqu'il y a pas
de majorité à l'Assemblée et que les
textes viennent comme ça un peu sans
sans
le sens on sait pas trop quelle est la
ligne mais justement sur la ligne est-ce
que vous vous sentez pas plus proche ou
de la ligne Macron borne que de la ligne
retailleau-ci non c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe à travers les textes que on
discute simplement à un moment donné à
la rentrée après les élections
sénatoriales il va falloir savoir
comment on travaille on peut pas
continuer à travailler dans ces
conditions-là on est un pays qui est la
cinquième ou 6e puissance mondiale
aujourd'hui il y a la guerre aux portes
de l'Europe en Ukraine il y a des
besoins de réforme on a 3000 milliards
de dettes à un moment donné le problème
c'est pas les petits jeux politiciens
pour savoir qui fait quoi le problème du
groupe les républicains le groupe
centrisme sera plus un aller à
conditionnel le groupe
conditionnalités on travaille il y a une
majorité sénatoriale ici au Sénat en
travaillant ensemble on parle des textes
ensemble on se met d'accord parfois on a
des désaccords mais on les gère ensemble
donc se posera à la question après les
prochaines élections sénatoriales de
savoir les conditions dans lesquelles on
travaille mais il y aura et je suis tout
à fait confiant sur le fait qu'il y aura
toujours une majorité sénatoriale et je
suis convaincu qu'elle sortira renforcer
à l'issue de ces prochains jours vous
entendez les bruits sur la manière dont
ça peut se passer en automne je rappelle
les propos de Gérard Larcher qui
parlaient de risque d'accidentologie et
donc qui avait une sorte de menace de
censure Olivier Marleix aussi à menacé
de censure est-ce que vous êtes en
accord avec cette stratégie de la ligne
rouge et de la masse permanente
moi je suis sénateur je suis pas député
donc je vais pas me mêler de ce qui se
passe à l'Assemblée nationale mais
j'aimerais être sûr de savoir
qui peut organiser quelque chose à
l'Assemblée nationale vous citez des
noms j'aimerais être sûr que s'ils
s'emporte l'adhésion de l'ensemble de
leur au moment des repères en mesure de
de porter une notion de censure et de la
faire passer
de leur plein gré c'est ça il y a pas de
direction particulière en fait
oui il y a une réunion hier soir à
Renaissance
si on veut éviter l'immobilisme est-ce
que vous avez vous pensez qu'il faut un
accord de coalition
avec Renaissance
ça peut en effet
une question sur la liste de excusez-moi
pardon j'étais parti sur autre chose il
y avait une question qui se posait sur
votre liste la seconde place est-ce que
elle sera dévolue à la présidente du
MoDem 92 Isabelle Floren qui n'est autre
que la fille du sénateur Jean-Marie vend
Laurent Berger
elle a été députée et c'est quelqu'un
qui qui mène une carrière
dans les Hauts-de-Seine on se connaît
depuis longtemps et effectivement
quelque chose me dit qu'il est pas
impossible qu'elle finisse par
travailler avec moi sur cette donc c'est
validé
déjà ça j'espère que le tête de liste
pourra être élu
si on peut en faire deux ou davantage et
pour votre quand on est candidat on
espère au mieux et pour votre groupe le
plus
[Applaudissements]
de chance
au club des territoires